the compromise agreed between the
australian government
and facebook has been welcomed by users
and is a victory in the short term at
least
for australia's news outlets who'll have
their facebook pages restored
well facebook has re-friended australia
and australian news will be restored to
the facebook platform and facebook has
committed
to entering into good faith negotiations
with
australian news media businesses in
seeking to reach
agreements to pay for content
facebook has agreed to invest tens of
millions of dollars into australia's
struggling news sector
in return it'll avoid mandatory payments
that could have cost it vastly more
and created what it sees as an alarming
global president
at the end of the day facebook's
accepted the premise that there needs to
be an accommodation between their
their market dominance in advertising in
the public interest of having journalism
and news content in australia the social
media giant sparked outrage last week by
blocking news content for its australian
users
in protest against legislation that
would have forced it to pay
media companies when it republished
their content
google faced the same threat but took
the opposite approach striking a deal
with rupert murdoch's news call
i think facebook well in my view might
have misjudged this one and
i think the market's going to respond
pretty strongly with competing
places to get news but if you're an
active
facebook user you just have to get into
the habit of collecting your news from
alternative
platforms there's been years of
escalating tension between governments
and big tech many saw facebook's
blocking of australian media as an
attack on free speech
and even a threat to democracy and that
could alter the road to regulation
putting companies like facebook under
more pressure than ever before
similar laws already being discussed in
the eu and canada
the news ecology has been radically
disrupted in the last little while
and i think there is a global appetite
for regulation and a global appetite
for facebook and google and others to
pay something
for the news that is linked to from
their platforms and i think this is just
one step in that process
google and facebook have two months to
reach further deals with australian news
outlets and avoid being forced to pay
victoria gatenbee al jazeera